Tik Tok is one of the most dangerous
social media kids under the age of 16
should not be using addictive social
media 150 million people are on Tik Tok
that means they can get your contacts
they can get your financial information
politicians threatening to ban Tik Tok
gives me more red flags than a toxic
Tinder date this is me in 2009 getting a
taste of Communism when I lived in China
the CCP blocked access to Myspace
Facebook and Twitter it's why I'm so
concerned to see American politicians
also try to block social media apps
candidates say we should please think of
the children in the same debate these
candidates advocated for parental rights
don't parental rights apply to social
media use too Banning Tech products
under the guise of National Security
will have unintended consequences
remember the Patriot Act the same
government that wants to ban Tik Tok has
been using the NSA to spy on Americans
for decades if you're worried about Tik
Tok don't download it if you don't want
your kids using it monitor their screen
time but whatever you do do not let
politicians Boogeyman social media the
same way the CCP does